The Prisoner class starts with this a
shield depicting a Sinister Rift that
glares back at the beholder it's likely
a reference to the ever jails Rifts that
serve as little pocket dimensions for
many prisoners in the lands between we
don't know much about the ever jails but
it's possible that they're linked to the
glint Stone Sorcerers our first clue are
their Sentry stones and imp Golems these
are likely creations of the golum
crafter who used Crystal tools the
Glenstone Sorcerers also rely on those
same crystals not to mention the
Glenstone Sorcerers do make frequent use
of the ever jails even the spell
Starlight suggests that Sorcerers were
familiar with such imprisonment and so
we return to the prisoner starting class
who bears that Rift shield and who is
also a sorcerer wielding Glenstone Magic
The Prisoner was and I quote convicted
of an appalling crime and I suspect they
were once very familiar with the inside
of an Ever jail this explains why